[Music]
we are a circus a big family tradition
and would the way we present our show is
the same way that my family presented
the show over 175 years ago there's
nothing fancy about what we do here it's
magic real magic we grew up in a circus
as a child you just step into being a
clown we're a classic family circus
which means our families here working
together performing together first of
all is my mother the matriarch of our
family then I have my sister Carla who
with her husband Rudy they perform with
her dog act and then way my sister Tosca
she has two horses on the show but she
also directs the show her husband Jay is
an amazing white clown the white clown
is the straight Club he's the best white
pawn that I've ever seen
fact that my son and I do right now in a
show is actually a balloon routine it's
nothing new I mean it's thousands of
years old cause haven't done it forever
it happens to be really cute when he
does it because he's adorable
it's an it's a unexplainable thing to
see my child do what he loves to do I
mean this is Agatha's seven-year-old
beautiful little boy and his heart opens
up and he gives it to everybody it's
different here I think for the most
person when we come into this ring we
become family
I believe circus and family are
basically the same work
you